I had a couple of friends visit last
week and I borrowed a golf cart and I
was showing them the town square and
this Trent the tram came by like going
with all the tourists yeah I was like oh
what am I supposed to do like am i
recognizable or am I not
so the tram pulls up I'm in this little
golf cart with my friends and people are
like people are looking at the clock
tower which is the other way and I was
like let me discreetly get out of here
so I went to go hit the gas but the horn
is next to the gas and I hit the horn
and all of the people turned this way
and I was like well now I don't know I'm
supposed to do so I was like sorry
everybody and they all just went and
start so I was like ok well I guess I
waved and I was part of the tour and
I've done the kinds of movies where
usually people have had a few before
they were taken before they watch it's
fine party movies yeah so sometimes I'll
be at a bar and people will recognize me
or think they recognize me but actually
recognized like Aziz or Kunal Nayyar
know this this is not supposed to be a
dark story I became guilty of like if
I'm out with friends and I'm like not
having the best day and if somebody is a
little drunk and goes are you kal penn
I've been known to Co what do you think
we all look alike No
[Laughter]
and I feel bad I feel bad I mean usually
I'll be like I'm totally getting him
totally kidding
but I have gotten a couple of free beers
off of Aziz and Kunal I will not stop
talking until you subscribe to my
youtube channel that's right and I could
talk a lot seriously not gonna stop yep
still here not going anywhere I see you
don't walk away from this